[Music]
greetings and welcome welcome to a wolf
in Sheet's clothing I'm your host
blessings WI our guest today is a
brilliant scientist who also preaches at
the Three Angels Church in Newington
Connecticut a graduate of University of
Miami school of medicine and lalinda
University School of Public Health where
he received his master's and doctorate
in public health having served President
George W bush and President Barack Obama
as an adviser on HIV and AIDS his wealth
of knowledge and expertise provides
perspective in an era where critical
thinking is being replaced by media and
entertainment he's a practicing
physician healthc care administrator and
travels the globe speaking on many
subjects we welcome Dr Eric Walsh on
this episode titled spirits of demons
working Marvels welcome to the set thank
you for having me I'm so glad that you
made it we want to jump right in uh
within the context of Revelations
unclean spirits absolutely absolutely so
um I would I would actually go back to
the greatest of all prophets to start
off with the greatest of all of the
prophets is Jesus himself Amen in
Matthew chapter 24 the apost the the pro
the apostles the then disciples are
asking Jesus when will these things be
and what will be the signs of your
coming and of the end of the world
that's Matthew
24:3 Jesus says something profound in
Matthew 24:4 he does not begin to tell
them the signs he doesn't jump into what
what's going to happen he does that in
Matthew 246 and 7 and on but before he
says something else he says see that you
be not deceived he he doesn't start
right telling you what's going to happen
he warns you first that this is going to
be an era of deception the word for
deceive there is the Greek word PLO it
means to be led away it's the same word
used in the parable of the 99 and one
sheep for the one sheep that went away
it was Plano it was led away so it's
very appropo for the title of this show
a wolf and sheep's clothing amen because
really we have to be careful that in
these last days things are going to look
like sheep but they're actually going to
be wolves Jesus gives that that us that
warning initially when we go to the Book
of Revelation and we look at some of the
verses it really gets interesting and
the reason I think um as we're going to
talk about media now there's got to be a
way for this deception to happen if you
stay in Matthew 24 there's an
interesting verse where Jesus says you
know there will be false Christ if they
say to you he's out in the fields do not
go but it also says if he's in in the in
a modern translations if he's in the
closet do not go right and I I honestly
believe that that is like almost if for
us we could take that as a reference to
modern technology it's not just that
false christs are going to come in
person National Geographic many years
ago had a great Magazine with all of
these false uh christs f from all over
the world really profound all the people
follow him but the what about the false
christs that are going to come because
of media and its influence right and how
do you see this playing out in
technology well one of the things is so
let's step back as a physician I like to
step back and we look at why this the
media is so dangerous and I know some of
your other guests going talk about music
so let's start with music quickly first
sure music bypasses The frontal Lo some
people say it doesn't but it literally
does it by doing that you don't co uh
consciously evaluate what you're
listening to to song the same way you do
when you are um hearing someone speak so
you're saying your filter is gone your
filter is at least muted okay now why is
that so dangerous because learning is
increased fivefold when you put
information to song and let me say this
to all the churches out there all the
pastors all the music leaders this is
why what you play in church matters
because a lot of the music of the day is
very what I call 7-Eleven seven words 11
times
very catchy very nice but no Doctrine no
instruction no words that'll help you
during a time of trouble feeling
productive but not actually absolutely
rendering the spirit Paul says in in 2
Timothy chapter 3 he says having a for
second Timothy chapter 3:5 having a form
of godliness but denying the power
thereof which is the power of the holy
spirit so when we look at this the music
when you play secular music and um I
know you'll have some musicians on but
when you play it you're literally
allowing in the enemy direct access
beyond your reasoning capabilities and
that's dangerous the frontal lobe of the
brain is where that reasoning happens
Isaiah 1118 come let us reason together
right salvation in its core is a is a
reasoning process this is why
righteousness is by faith faith is a a
something that you've reasoned something
that you've thought about something that
you accept and believe music bypasses
that so now the devil has this ability
to go deep in you and affect you with
the words to these songs so why is this
so relevant because we now know and I
know you have other guests talk about
people like alist Crowley and the
influence that he's had on the music
industry um you just to give you some
off the top of the head uh rap lyrics
Kanye West once wrapped and I know he
has a church now but he once wrapped you
know um he still does even in that yep
environment and he Kanye West has this
lyric where he actually says um I sold
my soul to the devil and it's a blank
deal at least it came with a few toys
like a Happy Meal
and as a youth pastor actually have seen
young people who've told me in an effort
to gain Fame they've thought about I
even had one who said he did try and
sell his soul to the devil um what we
know is that when music bathes over the
brain like this like I said your
learning is increased it stimulates the
the amydala the more emotional part of
the brain turns off the reasoning part
there's studies great studies out of the
American Journal of Pediatrics which is
not a Christian Journal by any stretch
of the imagination but you know it's a
secular scientific magazine they have
really good articles going back to 2006
showing that when children listen to
music with highly sexual content they're
far more likely to be G engage in
high-risk behaviors uh earlier than
children who don't so music has power
right um and this is one of the ways
that the media um you know when we flew
in you know um a big star is playing in
town here and the guy that was checking
Us in for the rental car basically was
as if he worshiped this person so the
message that they're giving has a lot to
do with that so that's music and the way
it affects the brain tons of ult in it I
know you'll hit it on other shows but I
also wanted to jump to television when I
was a kid we had four channels today
they have hundreds of channels they have
streaming services there's an almost
unlimited the scripture says in
Revelation 12 that when the woman wanted
to destroy the child um that um there
was a I mean when the dragon want
destroyed the child a flood that came
out right MH of his mouth to basically
wash them away I believe that that's
almost like what we're seeing it's a
flood there's such an increased volume
of material to try and confuse and
destroy our children so what I'm hearing
you say is basically that media in all
forms is being weaponized with
spiritualism it is absolutely being
weaponized and television to go because
you know a lot of people don't think a
TV like we used to at least when I was
growing up television actually changes
your brain waves and and lowers them
them to one where you're more in a semi
hypnotic state which accomplishes the
same thing music does except with the
added Dimension that you still have
music you still have and so you actually
go down and you'll accept what's being
said in a different way same thing they
have all these great studies about
cigarettes the reason they try to take
make people not smoke cigarettes in
movies now is they've shown that if kids
watch someone smoke a cigarette in a
movie they're far more likely to
actually smoke cigarettes themselves
like that's fact like the public health
fact imagine what happens mhm when it's
a TV show like Lucifer mhm right where
Lucifer is the good guy and Michael
Michael is the messed up bad guy bad
brother of Lucifer so this is narcism
basically playing out AB except now if
you take the fact that Evolution which
to me is another form of spiritualism
yes but if you take Evolution and you
and you brand every child with it
through school they they grow up
watching um their favorite children's
programming from big TV produc producing
companies and all of them have in common
magic Witchcraft and the Occult there's
no wonder that the fastest growing
religion among Youth and Young adults in
America is wickah and Witchcraft I find
it interesting as well because when I
was growing up uh the type of cultures
that were highlighted in these big you
know production houses were majoritively
white families and now you see it
branching into different communities you
know you have Coco uh which is a colum
set in colia uh you have uh the Princess
and the Frog new orle American princess
and what's the the Lilo and Stitch
Hawaii absolutely they're so the devil
you know unfortunately we divide up by
race the devil doesn't care what color
you are he wants to destroy your
character he wants you to not look like
Christ in character but he'll use he
will use all the whammy of you know
absolutely racism you in fact it's a
synergistic effect he will take the fact
that we live in a world of Injustice
where people do get hurt and where bad
things do happen and people are
Prejudiced and he will leverage that as
he did the disciples and we'll talk more
about this probably later but he did
that to the people at the time of Christ
who chose barabus over Christ why did
they do it it had everything to do with
politics and wanting to be liberated now
so how do you see the role of
spiritualism in politics connected to
Media well first and foremost um you
what you're watching now is that many of
these shows many of these many of the TV
shows for kids and teenagers support
this idea of social justice almost by
any cost ancestor worship has been
introduced um Christianity almost to a
letter you almost every Hollywood movie
TV show song Everything one of the
unifying themes across all of Hollywood
and all of entertainment is that
Christians are mean they're not kind
they're Hypocrites um it's a false
religion uh this is the enemy um I've
heard people they're the reason why
we're suffering so much the whole world
is in the mess it's in because of
Christianity not any of the other major
religions in the world just Christianity
and you know this because of the way
Islam and Hinduism are accepted they're
exalted in facted in every single
commercial I look at you see someone in
a you know meditative pose a
transcendental kind of meditative pose
and there's no push back for that
absolutely and for the parents out there
especially you really have to guard the
The Avenues of the Soul as we are
instructed from Young because these
things will breed to Rebellion later on
what you behold by beholding you become
changed and there's a scripture that
says Rebellion is as the sin of
Witchcraft now it's also not just what
we behold in the sense of seeing like
you discuss music has another way of
coming in and as you become a
demoralized and depleted person in
society does that make you then more
susceptible to accepting whatever the
common culture gives you absolutely well
part of what you know I say this in a
lot of my messages um when there's no
purpose when there's no purpose pleasure
becomes the highest calling so when you
strip people through evolution of the
idea of a Creator who loves them the
fact that they're made in God's image
all of the pieces of that and the
Sabbath is directly connected to that
now one reason I think it helps people
live longer all of that is Stripped Away
way by the way we're raised today in
school and in society even the movies
promote Evolution right 10,000 BC and
Jurassic Park and all this stuff I AG
all I say all of that all of even for
the little kids when you strip that away
from a child then you the child has to
ask well why am I here and then what is
given to them through social media which
is the third leg of this media thing is
social media which is probably the most
dangerous of the three now because of
how addictive we now know it is and the
Damage it does to the brain but when you
when you look at that now what the kid
is learning is that there's only one
real religion it's the religion of self
it's the religion of pleasure so you can
get really deep into Eastern religions
that will actually codify this and and
present it to you in a way that's kind
of more formal or it can simply be the
nightclub life trying to figure out a
way to get the next high and so what
happens is this occult movement the
spiritualism ties then into something
else that's happening we have an
epidemic of addiction right in a
12-month period dur dur the pandemic
over 100,000 Americans died of drug
overdoses that is a staggering number in
12 months we are on Pace to continue
those kind of numbers what's actually
happening when I worked in addiction
medicine one of the things that um one
of the veterans I worked at the VA
Hospital Linda one of the veterans said
God made the human heart so big only he
can fill it
amen when our kids are watching this
stuff when they're getting addicted to
social media ultimately leading in many
ways to addiction to other things it's a
it's the hole they're trying to fill
exacerbates it deepens it yeah and they
can't fill that hole mm without Christ
they can't fill out there's a study that
says that we touch our phones at least
2, something like 600 times a day so is
there a relationship between how much we
touch the phone and maybe how it
registers in the brain well what we know
I don't about directly touching it but
looking at it the way that they design
social media is that you scroll up
because then there's no bottom so you're
constantly trying to find the bottom of
the feed and there is no bottom so you
stay addicted to it and of course we
have what we're doing and this mixes the
occult with the science of control of
Mind Control by doing this you're
training people to have very short
attention spans which it leads to the
rise in ADHD absolutely and here's where
it really gets funny now how difficult
is it then to sit in church through a 45
minute sermon H if all week all you've
ever spent focusing on an idea was 10 8
7 Seconds mhm and so CH now and then all
week every song every show every social
media you know exploration is entwined
with demonic spirits and this is what I
tell parents a lot of times as a youth
pastor the one of the reasons our
children don't like coming to church is
because when they come to church by
God's grace they enter a place where the
spirit of God is dwelling it's a
tabernacle the holy spirit is there but
all week they've been listening to
playing with being entertained by the
spirits of the enemy so it's a diet of
spiritualism and occultism so how
comfortable can you actually be in
church if all week you were dealing with
those dark spirits and so we got to
clean up our house a lot of times before
we can get to kids and so you see this
targeted attack on children because it's
the developmental phase where they
actually would connect and Proverbs
tells us raise up you know a child in
the way that he should go and when he's
old he will not depart from it
absolutely so yeah so the target is the
children everybody needs to know that
obviously it doesn't go away even as we
get older Satan tries to use these
influences just to move us in one
direction or the other and we as
Christians have to be made up in our
minds that we're not going to let this
in right we love the I love the the
image and the Bible verse where Jesus
stands at the door and knocks he says if
you let me in I will I will come in and
I will Su with you the reason a lot of
folk Can't Let Jesus in when he's
knocking is because they're already
entertaining someone else in the house
and that is a dark spirit and maybe not
just one and maybe not just one um and
so you know from the media all these
different things are happening it's
moving us in a certain direction um it's
creating a new environment a rebellion
against Christianity so we're seeing the
number of Christians people who identify
as Christian in general in the country
decline the number of those are called
that uh defined defined as the nuns n o
n es that number is increasing so you're
watching meaning I don't identify with
any religion absolutely so they have no
religious identification so you're
watching this transition and I guess the
scariest part of it is that now you're
moving the country in a direction where
these Spirits can do their work right so
that now if you stand for principle if
you stand for God you are the enemy and
you're attacked and and it can come from
anywhere a swarm of enemies within a
moment I've seen people get shut down
like on Twitter if they say say
something conscientious or something
that's against the grain so I can
imagine you know the Bible forewarns
that in the future you know we're going
to be the enemy and attacked for
defending God and now you can get shut
down I know that you had a personal
experience with this could you touch on
that Bri yeah so I you know I was I was
actually working in government in
Southern California and um was invited
to be the commencement speaker um for um
for one of the community colleges and
didn't know know that they had already
invited someone to speak um who was a
very prominent in the lgbtq community
and um I had my job actually worked a
lot with that Community because we had
an HIV program at at the health
department and we were doing a lot of
great work around that but when some of
the students and the group was called
the students for social justice when
they found out that he had been replaced
the the the the um the president of
school wanted me to speak inste instead
they came after me and all they could
find were sermons and it was enough I
mean the whole world rallied against me
and I give give the full testimony
elsewhere but it really was deep and it
was dark mhm it was demonic um literally
one of the interesting story just to
show every I want everyone the viewers
to really understand the the spiritual
war we are in I found out I had to
basically God took me and and put me in
a safe place on a small island called
Guam as a missionary while all of this
was unfolding and while I was working
through what was going on but I got a
call from one of the Christians I used
to work with um back in Southern
California to tell me one of the
organizations that I worked with the
person who ran it was so angry with me
and she was from that Community she was
so angry with me that um she told her
she was going to get a voodoo doll no
and she was going to begin to stick the
voodoo doll with pins voodoo doll of me
and stick it with pins to destroy me and
I told this young lady because my
grandmother our family is Jamaican and
my grandmother used to deal with what
they call the obia ladies on the island
of Jamaica my grandmother was no joke I
said listen no weapon formed against me
will prosper I am covered by the blood
of the Lamb so obia meaning obia is like
is is the Jamaican word kind of for
Voodoo um and so this lady did all that
and you know what happened she passed
away I mean I'm not not not that I
celebrate that but nothing came to me
right and I so I want the I want viewers
to know that as we talk about this you
can stand on the word of God and on
these principles there's protection and
coverage in these words absolutely and
so when you are faced with these things
as we as we go on WE these things are
going to become more manifest as the
spirit of God is being removed from the
earth as Hollywood becomes more bold um
as the politicians become more bold with
this stuff as this begins to happen and
we feel like we're being uh attacked I
challenge the viewers and all of us you
know involved in in the truth and
spreading it claim the promises of God
there is that's why the the the in the
armor of God in in the book of Ephesians
it's says to take the shield of Faith
right right the fiery darts of the enemy
cannot penetrate that how do we get
faith faith comes by hearing the word of
God I encourage people I want to be
practical with the viewers right now
after what I went through and I'm they
got just a just the sprinkles on the top
of the ice cream cone version of this
right now I want them to know that when
these things happen you can Retreat into
the word of God and it is a fortress
that's right and the blood of Jesus
Christ will cover you and what what I
encourage people to do is to get old
school index cards write bible promises
on them and walk with them walk with 105
cards when trial comes your way when
difficulty comes your way when the enemy
seems like he's going to rise up against
you like a flood pull out a card and
read a promise and say out loud I claim
the promise of God that's right that is
powerful if you ever read uh Roger monno
one of the great Adventist um writers um
and of course he came out of demon
Worship in Montreal Canada U Back in the
40s 50s after World War II Charmed by
Darkness Charmed by Darkness um tripping
into the supernatural he also wrote the
book beware of angels incredible answers
to prayers and one of the things that um
he says is that when the demons tried to
get him back and they would come and
attack him he would recite out loud from
Matthew
26:27 he memorized and would recite
verbatim the story of the crucifixion
crci and it would hold back the demons
right amazing he also said that the
demon priest told him when he was still
in that stuff um when they say the demon
priest said that there are two lies that
the world believes one is um that Sunday
is the day of worship and two is that
when you die you live on he said Satan
re Revels in the fact that the world
believes these two lies Roger mono says
a hand went up in the back if you anyone
reads the book a hand went up in the
back of the room and said what about the
Adventists the Sabbath Keepers the Damon
priest laughed haah I don't mention them
there's so few of them mhm he said but
we cannot deceive them no because they
keep the Sabbath amen I want to
encourage people that you're on the
wrong you're on the right side of this
war you go back and look at Revelation
CH 12 look at Revelation chapter 13
you're on the right side You've Won
already and so you don't have to be
afraid spiritualism doesn't have to make
you afraid because for every demon right
God has two angels amen amen now I also
see that there's a trend and an effort
not only with the spiritualist but also
even with people within so-called
Christianity where they're trying to
rewrite the Bible including AI you know
there's going to be a book and a lot of
people don't know that this is under
underway that it's going to happen I
think the most dangerous area so we're
talking about media and
spiritualism the most dangerous place
that this is going to happen is actually
going to be inside the church one of the
ways that this is going to happen is
through false revivals that will
actually be demonic and one of the signs
that it will be a false Revival is that
there will be no call to repentance no
need to change the character is fine
just the way you are they stop the
gospel at come as you are they don't
keep on with where Jesus says you know
neither do I condemn you go and sin no
more they leave out that last part A
Revival that is focused on feeling good
so musically LED music that heavily and
very little bible some of the great tele
evangelists of our day the wealthiest
with largest churches literally never
read the Bible that's a sign I just saw
a footage of what was known as holy yoga
No holy laughter I saw that before
incredibly demonic and even yoga has
holy yoga and laughter Yoga and the same
outcome that would come of the
participants was what I saw in yoga was
the same that I saw in this you know
Evangelical version of it you so so
we're going to see that from the but the
other scary part though is we're going
to see this movement because people
believe that when you die you don't
really die spiritualism at its core
rests in great part on that lie that you
die and you continue on so when you look
at um a lot of our churches whether
they're Catholic churches or or or or or
Evangelical Protestant churches they
believe this lie people are going to
begin to appear to them and be able to
say hey do this or do that I've heard
people already saying that right we've
seen it also in beware of angels
absolutely who were actually Adventists
who knew the Bible truth who knew the
Sabbath truthed and were
deceived and now to let let's take the
spiritualism thing to the next level so
in the church there's so much more we
can talk about in church we we we'll
probably hit that next episode but
there's another really scary thing I
don't know if everybody's aware of the
UFO phenomenon yes that is being really
highly touted now if you're a Christian
and you're and you don't really
understand the word when these I mean of
government former government officials
in front of Congress saying they have
biologics from from Aliens and ships
that they're trying to reverse
engineer what what happens when one of
these aliens speaks well the world has
been prepared through media with shows
like ET Star Wars you can go on and on
all of these things Rec Total Recall all
of this has prepared you for the idea
that these aliens
exist but if you're a Bible believing
Christian you know there aren't there's
no beings from other planets visiting
this one no we're the only world that
sinned right they would never come here
so who's visiting these are demonic dark
Forces and so interesting thing is when
you look at science fiction you look at
the Sci-Fi channel the two programs they
have Ghost Hunters they do yeah that's
now under science fiction and then you
have the this a lot of this Ancient
Aliens and all of these different shows
on History Channel I want people to to
understand that the prophecies that
we've heard about these demons going out
in the world to deceive the world is
beginning to happen already yes it is
we're closer to the end than we we we
can even imagine and if you don't
understand what we believe you're really
in big
trouble wisely said you know our time is
coming to an end and I know you're going
to be back for a second episode we're
going to dive into politics and
spiritualism thank you so much thank you
Proverbs 226 council's parents train up
a child in the way he should go and when
he is old he will not depart from it
ancestor worship is being promoted
across all networks from ABC Disney to
sci-fi channels including subscription
channels like Netflix and Hulu films
that are targeted at children like Coco
Harry Potter and the last Bender which
exposed children to elements of
Witchcraft necromancy and Mystic ISM
spiritualism is covertly and blatantly
marketed across all platforms of media
disenfranchising Christians and training
up an army of wicked youth we urge
parents at home please don't sacrifice
your children by placing them in front
of such media you shouldn't even listen
to this demonic music please take the
time to read your Bible heed the words
of Dr Walsh we've run out of of time
thank you for joining
[Music]
[Applause]
us
[Music]